Let us look at how the process of configuration would work in detail.
Recorder will met a file of represent in reason, will represent knowledge and
then reason over it. So suppose it asked the configure a chair. We must then
somehow represent all of the knowledge of this chair then we can reason over it.
So we will represent all of our knowledge of the chair in the form of a frame.
Here's is the frame, here are the beta slots. For the time being,
let's just assume that there are six slots that are important. The last four of
the slots may point to their own frames. So there might be a frame for legs,
a frame for seat, and so on. Now some of these frames have slots like size, and
material, and cost. For legs, you may have an additional slot like count.
What is the number of legs on the chair? And this particular frame
representation captures of the knowledge of the generic, prototypical chair.
To do configuration design is to come up with a specific arrangement of all
the parts to this particular chair, to assign values to each of the variables,
which means filling out the fillers for each of the slots. Of course, the values
of these variables depends in part on the global constraints of mass and
cost. We may, for example, have a global constraint on the mass of the chair, or
in the cost of the chair, or both. We may have additional constraint as well.
For example in material of a chair might become an,
perhaps the material needs to be metal.